DANNY: Jeanette and Joe-- man,
these are some cool people.
They brought us
their beloved Bronco
to get some very special
custom touches on her
and to make sure that
she's ready to rock
for at least another 20 years.
Nick did an amazing
job commemorating some
of the family heroes on
the hood of this truck,
and I cannot wait to see
the look in their eyes
when they land on this beautiful
brand-new 20-year-old Bronco.
I gotta ask you some questions
before we get into the Bronco,
OK?
Now what year is
this again? '90--
- '96.
And you've had her for how long?
I'm the original owner.
- The original owner of this?
- Yeah.
This is a really nice vehicle.
So what are you all going
to do with this truck now?
Well, we're still going
to keep it as our workhorse.
We're going to drive it around.
Your workhorse?
JOE: Yeah.
It's too beautiful
to be a workhorse.
I know, but then what's
the sense of having it
if you can't show it off?
I love it.
It's really cool, and I
think you guys are going
to have a ball in it, so--
- You're getting me going now.
- [laughing]
- Should we just look at it?
- Yes.
Quit talking about it?
Come on.
All right.
I'm ready.
Ryan, come on, man.
[music playing]
Bring out that Bronco.
[engine starting]
Soak it in.
Oh wow.
JEANETTE: What is that?
[laughing] Wow.
Oh, god.
Wow.
Look at-- unbelievable.
Beyond my wildest dreams.
DANNY: We made some necessary
mechanical and cosmetic fixes
on this Bronco to make her look
like new, but man, oh, man.
Ryan's beautiful paint job
coupled with Nick's portrait
work transformed
this Bronco's hood
into a piece of art
that would look right
at home hanging in a museum.
But we didn't stop there, man.
We installed that
brand-new crate
engine straight from Ford,
disc brakes all the way around.
And inside, Pauly did that
beautiful double diamond
stitched interior,
complete with a gun
safe in the center console.
I'm so proud of my guys
and how beautifully
they did this truck.
You brought us a very
original, clean vehicle.
So everything has been
gone through on her,
and then we put a brand-new
set of tires on it.
These are Cooper Discoverer
A/T3's, so brand-new.
Nobody's got these yet.
They're a whole new line
that Cooper's come out with.
These are their All-Terrain 3's.
American made--
they're fantastic.
So you're going to dig the
ride on that going along.
OK.
DANNY: The drivetrain-- all new.
The engine-- all new.
Everything is all new, so she
drives like a brand-new truck,
like she should.
And she looks better than any
brand-new truck could look.
Originally, what you
guys started out with
was an Eddie Bauer
edition Bronco.
What I wanted to do was
get a little '70s in it
from the older
model Broncos where
they brought the two-tone line
on the bottom over the wheel
well.
They kind of pushed the fender
flares out a little bit.
Lowers the top of the
vehicle, but makes
the bottom of the
vehicle look much higher.
And he slipped in some
beautiful stars and stripes.
JOE: Yes.
DANNY: You guys
wanted it patriotic,
but you didn't want to make
a billboard out of it, so--
JOE: Correct.
Correct.
[click]
- There it is.
There it is.
Oh, wow.
So literally everything
under the hood is factory Ford,
but it's brand-new.
JOE: Wow.
DANNY: So this is
ready to be driven
for another gazillion
miles, and you're not going
to have any issues with it.
And I will.
DANNY: Absolutely.
It's done everywhere inside now.
Watch your hands.
[thump]
Solid.
Rock solid.
The mural on the hood--
who we got here?
JOE: That's my father.
DANNY: That's your father.
JEANETTE: In the Navy, yeah.
JOE: In World War II.
JEANETTE: In the Navy.
DANNY: In World War II.
JOE: Right.
DANNY: God bless him.
- My brother.
- Your brother.
He was in Vietnam War
also, during that time frame.
DANNY: Amen.
JOE: Myself.
DANNY: Yourself.
That's a handsome
man right there.
ALL: [laughing]
DANNY: I love it.
JEANETTE: That's
the man I married.
[laughing]
DANNY: I love it.
Oh, my god, I love it.
JOE: This is my nephew Brian.
DANNY: How do you
feel about the hood?
Oh--
Correct?
No words could
describe how I'm feeling.
Amen.
From the bottom my heart,
I can't thank you enough.
JEANETTE: We're taking our
family with us wherever we go.
That's beautiful.
Man, I'm so glad that
Jeannette and Joe are
thrilled with this truck, man.
And I'm so happy that
another military tribute
vehicle has come out of
my shop, Count's Kustoms.
Glad you guys are
happy, and that's all--
JEANETTE: More than happy.
- That's what we wanted.
JEANETTE: It's got
your stink on it.
Amen.
JEANETTE: [laughing]
DANNY: Got our stink
all over it, baby.